many of us will be spending this holiday
weekend out on the water in a lake river
or Bay sales of recreational power boats
boomed during the pandemic while they
leveled off a bit last year an estimated
000 new boats were sold in 2022. of
course the vast majority of those were
gas-powered boats but just like with
cars the future of boating may be
electric Joy Benedict found one company
that's trying to power a sea change
good
it's the season of sunshine and sea
but sometimes the sound that takes you
there cuts through the silence and peace
that comes with being on the water
but now the wave of the future
sounds different what's your favorite
thing
the silence
everything's on right now you can hear
nothing
no noise pollution Francis pickworth has
been driving boats professionally for
more than a decade but now he's testing
them for Tech startup Arc offering the
first of its kind in electric watercraft
the technology and electric device is
just
that's the way forward it's the future
it's called The Arc one an all-electric
24-foot cruiser with power to hit speeds
of more than 40 miles an hour you have
instant torque
[Music]
instant fun that's torque right that is
torque this is my favorite way to spend
time I like fishing I like water skiing
wakeboarding
I like just cruising Mitch Lee is the
CEO of the Los angeles-based company and
sometimes captain of his experimental
ship we went from absolutely nothing
just two people and an idea to
delivering
customer boats to people in under two
years with the with the background in
engineering he teamed up with a friend
from college Ryan Cook to Electrify the
industry which is why a large portion of
his team came from SpaceX this is the
very first build station for our boats
built by hand The Arc one is constructed
less like a boat and more like something
headed out of this world
The Arc one is a fully aluminum boat
which when you squint starts to look
pretty close to a rocket in the sense
that it needs to be light it needs to be
strong and so so that talent and that
experience from the group from SpaceX
directly translated over to what we were
doing but Lee said he says the power
illegian electric vehicles specifically
the Tesla as their team of Engineers
built the batteries first and then the
whole of the vessel was crafted around
them these battery packs are huge how
much space does it actually take up of
the boat so what's very cool about this
boat is the battery packs essentially
make up the floor of the boat and they
run from approximately here on the boat
all the way to the back of it the weight
of the battery is half of the seven
thousand pound boat anchoring the ship
while the aluminum help keeps it light
for Speed and serves another purpose
being an aluminum boat we can also
directly benefit from that cooling using
the hole itself so it's basically like a
big giant aluminum cooler exactly so we
limit the speed right now to 41.
on the outside the arc one has all the
luxuries you'd expect a backup camera
temperature and Battery gauges similar
to an EV but with no gas tank or giant
engine there's more room for seating and
hidden champagne coolers
[Music]
but that performance doesn't come cheap
The Arc one retails for three hundred
thousand dollars and still sold out in
months we know that it is not
necessarily at a mass Market affordable
price so future boats will have
lower costs associated with them but
when you
as they go out on the water and they
and that's right electric boats make a
tremendous amount of sense because they
solve some of the most acute ownership
problems that people have hundreds of
dollars a day to take a boat out on a
lake with gas with gas that is compared
to just tens of dollars to refuel an
electric boat not having to fill up
would be kind of nice at the end of the
day Andrew hard owned several boat
rental clubs in Southern California he
says his only electric boat right now
tops out at just five miles an hour but
remains one of his most popular
reservations the other thing is the
maintenance on these is really easy so
an engine and a gas engine is going to
have a lot of moving parts we do a lot
of Maintenance to those boats these are
the easiest boats we have to maintenance
at this speed you can go for well over a
day on a single charge Lee says the next
generation of Arc boats will be lower in
cost and Target the power hungry Market
of water sports all right ready the
force behind the helm is addictive
and it's calm a contradiction
as the newest technology on the waves
may be the one thing that brings us all
closer to nature
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Joy
Benedict off the coast of Southern
California
I love Choice reaction ah oh
you should be on a boat it'll be
interesting to see because the design I
know for so many people that are boaters
is is something that they love and that
may be a different thing and so will
that develop to me as costs come down
the cost though three hundred thousand
dollars no this is why it's good to have
friends with boats yes regardless
because a regular boat is expensive also
we were a used boat around that size
would be about half the cost right now a
little bit more than half the cost but
that's a used boat not a new one yeah
only because we don't know what the cost
of a real boat that size would be
because we don't have boats just have a
friend that has a friend friends with
both